in this video we are going to do
something a bit different in that we
will showcase to you all the top 10
godzilla entrances taken from all his
movies
we know big g has had more movies than
any other character or creature
and his franchise has spanned over 66
years
and in this year alone he will be seen
again in two separate and different
incarnations
his entrances into each film is
different and in each one
there is always a sense of shock and awe
so here on minecube we will bring to you
a list of 10
of his most epic and badass entries from
our own judgment that is
and i bet many of you will have a list
that is very different from ours
so put them down in the comments section
and also subscribe for more monster
content so let's do this thing
number 10.
[Music]
number nine
number eight
[Applause]
number seven
[Music]
number six
number five
[Music]
what do you make of that all
[Music]
number four
number three
number two
glory such will shake the very heavens
and split the earth
and number one
[Music]
you